the only other objection I got is more like I'm not on the spot kind of guy really that was about it
which that comes back back to like the building urgency right like I don't give a fuck if you're
on the spot guy or not uh I don't care I'm here to find it like like you're not saying this but
you're you're you're you're kind of like exuding this by how you're saying it you're like I don't
give a fuck what you you are aren't we have a call I have a call in an hour you know I do this
exclusively are you in or at shit or get off the pot motherfucker like that's the mentality you have
to have and again also comes back to think in your head going like I'm the one that has what he needs
there's 20 of him there's one of me so I call the shots here and and even though you want that deal
you want that fucking deal so bad you have to make it seem like you don't need that deal right last
question last thing I'm gonna say uh is mostly whenever I'm trying to do create the urgency is
I'll do like next day so a lot of things I hear people say is like in an hour in two hours and
three hours I feel like most of the time like with the last two guys we've had a reschedule
for a two hour because he'll be on a job for 5 p.m and they'll be like dude can we do 7 p.m and
I'll be like sure but I do have a call with the guy in the next two days one day so is it really
better to do it like right then like next three hours or one yeah what I usually say is like I'm
just like hey you know uh I got a call I'm supposed to do a call sometime tomorrow afternoon so I just
want to make sure we're good that way you're not tied down to a time and you can still and I also
like to call that company and just kind of have an open conversation and let hey whatever I'm
you know I'm probably going to be working with someone but would you be interested in taking
leads that way if he happens to know that business owner and he calls him it's not like oh he's lying
yeah I like that perfect